[Music]
faces are the most important subject
matter in art it's a never-ending source
of material when you put on one of my
masks you become somebody different you
start to embody that character and have
a lot of fun with it
my name is Landon Meyer and I make
disturbingly realistic masks I never
thought I was gonna make a living doing
masks I was a picture framer loan
officer pizza delivery driver and then I
got laid off I've always been interested
in doing something that's like really
surreal and nightmarish so it was more
or less an experiment that took off I am
the only person out there that's doing
hyper realistic lightness masks I'm kind
of this weird mad scientist out of the
basement
I start off getting lots of reference
material the hardest part is doing the
sculpture that can take anywhere from
four days to a year but once the sculpt
is done and I have a mold it's about a
one week process to make a mask
they were ungodly expensive they ranged
$500 and up and sometimes even high as
$7,500 over the years I've made
approximately 25 different designs and
I've produced with my own hands over a
thousand masks
what I make I like to consider wearable
art these are super realistic sculptures
you can put over your head and where
people just seem to have this astonished
reaction to the masks that's what I love
about them
[Music]
[Music]
I often do look at the pile of stuff at
work and think maybe I should stick that
on my face the Bob bugs project started
was just my Instagram account and I
started using it for an art diary I got
an idea every day i disguised myself in
some way day 363 now for a creative
breakthrough my name is Michael Gump I
am an art director and a prop master for
crazy TV shows and I'm also known as Bob
bucks
the master disguised project is partly
to build creative strength or maybe to
like exorcise creative demons you know
in a way that's not just at my job but
also for my own evil wishes you look at
the picture maybe seems like it took a
million years I'm usually like I gotta
get this done I gotta get that side just
like I got my stuff and it's it all up
and search which I usually like you know
start with this area and then work my
way out and then it'll be like
people ask me what I'm like usually
nobody does it one that stands out in my
mind was like kind of like what am i
doing I I was putting clothes pins on my
face and so I started stick him on there
and then and then I kind of panic a
little bit I took them all off I was
like okay and then I was like okay this
is gonna be fine and then and then I put
them all back on like you get used to
discomfort pretty fast but I'm concerned
that it's definitely not that good for
my skin do you have a favorite I do have
a special place in my heart for the one
that's like a green mr. t because I just
think it's funny like mr. green tea I
call it it's been a kind of exhausting
process in some ways I usually only get
like maybe three hours of sleep a night
the discovery of the project and part of
the point of the project is that you
don't always know what's good so on the
days that I really feel tired and I
really want to do it I don't really have
a very good idea
sometimes those projects come out better
than the ones that I'm really excited
about what's next
we wrapped wait and see
[Music]
normally there's this awkwardness around
disability but with that costume on
there that changed how people saw my son
they saw him first before they saw his
disability
it just helps break down that barrier
magic wheelchair is a nonprofit that
builds epic costumes for amazing kiddos
and wheelchairs the magic wheelchairs
started when my son was three years old
Halloween rolled around and he wanted to
be a pirate we're new to the whole
disabilities and wheelchair thing we
didn't know anything about spinal
muscular atrophy I saw him sitting in
his wheelchair how we could dress them
up as a pirate be a pirate in a
wheelchair and let's let's build a ship
we have made probably about forty eight
different costumes we have teams right
now all over the country we have a team
in France and working on a team in
Australia we're just gonna keep on
boarding teams because we want to build
year round it's hard to build for people
that are in wheelchairs but it
ultimately starts with the kid it's
whatever they want to be and then we
make it a reality
[Music]
Halloween was kind of our initial push
but we're seeing like comic-con right
[Music]
and what's cool about that community of
cosplay that's a very supportive
community the the cold reality of
childhood diseases are some of them
won't be around for next Halloween so
let's find something that we can do
while they're here with us so they have
these that they have these great
memories and that they're their families
have memories when they're gone
[Music]
it's almost like a cure for the day
because they don't see the wheelchair
they just see these amazing kids and it
bridges gaps and overcomes that
awkwardness that we have in society I
mean their star the show oh it's awesome
to see
[Music]
Dupree nosotras important Dolce behave
ashes entrepreneurs oppa yet able C to D
to D so fo fum e de pruebas cursive opus
kosabu drama school
voila c'est votre nom au revoir M
appelle EDTA is responsibility Jamie's
effusive mesosphere is existed up in
unison applaud fun set a structure ahora
de de quoi de pareja ensuite Amazon's
especially Sedona question de Musique o
Musa Moses Isaiah prophesied on NT a
physician de Janeiro second on la la
fecha porque si esta pieza le pré
Messiah men para la ilaha medulla
primaporta la vo costume to te llama
Machida's to zalem m zu t via des années
cochon waffle a croissant window declare
jihad on de souza phenomena by do kapa
haka
[Music]
so no prima donna Denver Toit's Oh Polly
preeminence Upali Liz was Oporto Nala
print and dwelt CDs application
Lukashenko DiPrima oh ho ho no Canelo
trophy solo coca-cola pata Sita por todo
dia de su material for sale Elmo ha
Duncan citrus little wallet and can pre
certain survey not savoir faire le
transmetal DeGeneres Georgia has room de
varville nutrients US Embassy Kazuma
Paseo de ma vie de semana feet in
Philadelphia poor chap Thomas Eric
Antonio Watson travel in a yo-yo oval
Apollodorus salah vacant also valid to
travel on a moon listen wise in order
the preparation question syllable
teaming approach a Sarasota repro Eva
Antonia a contrary tener Avenida resna
some previously known as possible
ah ah sorry mrs. Vasquez tango
veintisiete Anya's avoid class and a
facultad de ciencias come my spider-man
to Merced is a casa con el distress
regardez pasado
hasta la universidad initial mentor
universidad cuando llegue knesset is
France todo tipo de acciones a gente que
mention estas loco pero con el tiempo de
la cuenta que son intention on insta yes
particle tell ya medicine a la mañana de
Ciencias a vestroia mass the connection
con una una y para daughter's gonna
distress not only the Dunamis from me
ruslan entry visas yo creo que realmente
no muscala fam'ly this is important
nokia noises in no cases the scene so
you say girls comics los evil agenda
Lucio collection and oh this is really
saw Selma como spider-man poor kun da
villian el transporte público lady in
the comics you know Navi nieta estaba
spider-man friend invisible Don the
classic edy hey si tengo que sería Ming
gundalia que la gente Vieira de todos
podemos Rosanna so trabajo siempre con
más Deanna's en me caso de spacer Mamie
motiva para ser un mejor profesor pero
cada quien debe encontrar la manera de
su trabajo con mayo felicidad
convocation
you
[Music]